Would you consider enlightened tutor a
draw spell? I mean, it's literally card
negative, so that would be stupid,
right? It actually depends. For one, if
you almost always use it to find
something that draws a lot of cards,
like Skull Clamp or Wristic Study, it
essentially takes on the function of a
draw spell. Though, it's a worse top
deck since it puts the card on top.
Secondly, whether or not a tutor should
be thought of as card draw really
depends on what task draw spells are
accomplishing in your deck. If you're
running draw spells like Esper Sentinel
and whirlwind of thought mainly to find
a key card like Jessica Ascendency or
Isaconceptor, a tutor like Enlightened
Tutor is accomplishing the same task and
differentiating them is pretty
pointless. It's a difference without a
distinction. Does this mean that tutors
are always interchangeable with draw?
Absolutely not. Often times a deck will
care more about advantage than it cares
about selection. And if you want some
examples of that, you can watch my
full-length video on the subject.